[Applause]
how are you how are you look at you than
you I love a I know Ed onesie I love a
grown-up onesie um how's your family
been very very good it's it's you know
Christmas time it's been beautiful big
family yeah you do have it you have five
kids right yeah and they're all mine
yeah can you believe it it's just a lot
it's a lot well do your kids cook yeah I
mean I've tried uh to subliminally
brainwash them throughout all stages of
their life do it uh they're normally
really good until about 12 and then when
the teens come it's like uhuh and then
I've noticed at College they don't want
me to know about it but they're actually
cooking they're like batch cooking
they're getting all their friends to put
money in and saving money cooking these
big feasts and then all the money saved
goes on booze party like okay you know
what if they're that clever it can cook
I'm okay with it yeah I think you know
that's the thing with kids man if you
just like it's little things and often
that count you don't have to do big
projects like just walking them like
through a farmers market once a month
you don't even have to spend any money
just walk them through they just pick up
stuff no you I I did not frequent a
grocery store we were poor I lived on
very poor food and so I never learned
really how to grocery shop I get
overwhelmed in a grocery store so I
think it's very important to and I think
that that scenario that you talk about
which is really important whether it's
the UK or the US quite uniquely like if
you go to the Mediterranean which is
where this book is centered yeah like if
you come from the projects if you're
poor they grow up around food they they
eat well they eat well on less and and
in this book with five ingredients less
you the shopping list is smaller you
spend less but also it makes you focus
on technique this is my favorite thing
you've been on here but I love that it's
five ingredients this is brilliant
because like I look at this and it's not
daunting like I hate when you get a book
and the ingredients are like this and
it's like prep 45 I'm like I am a single
mother stop there this is this is the
one for you no it is I've already do you
know I already have recipes like marked
on your B I'm not kidding cuz I I love
how easy it is I'm like okay I can go to
hoods and cuz also in New York carrying
all those bags of groceries shut up yeah
yeah yeah I get it I get it yeah also
the way we're living is changing so the
target you're the Target by the way um
the target is changing phones technology
delivery services living in cities out
in the country it's changing so my job
is to keep cooking alive because I
believe in it truly I know it can heal
you fix you make you happier from from
from a financial point of view honestly
truly and and and actually at this
moment in time in Britain and Amer we've
never cooked less yeah so my job is the
way I see it is quick easy affordable
let me hold your hand I'm dyslexic right
so words actually are on my enemy so on
the page I spend hours trying to have
less words like just like business let's
just knock out a lovely dinner I will
say like the five ingredients to when
you're talking to cuz my mom was a
single mom too so that's why there
wasn't a lot of time for that too and so
it's like in and she wasn't trained like
that you know either so it it's just if
it's overwhelming so I think this is
like the perfect perfect book for people
can I just say right you're not born to
cook right everyone has the capacity
yeah and it's not if it's always when
and I've I've met many times like people
in the 60s and 70s and they just got it
and the and the sorrow in their eyes is
is that it's 10 20 30 years too late
yeah and because it's yours you're a
musician like you got the band over
there like music and food art like it's
it can be simple and and the way you
feel and what you cook and what you
choose to buy and how it makes you feel
I I know I sound like a hippie but it's
true it's I'm a total hippie you're
talking to a musician no but honestly so
I I believe that you can be a great cook
and and I would put money on it I
believe okay here's the thing I can
actually cook well it just takes me you
know the little part where it says 15
minutes nope it takes me I freak out on
the wait how many was it how much was it
like I sit there just to get the
ingredients do that on the stage so what
you have to do is you need to just
convert that confidence and also the
recipes are there
to work you know they got to work but
they're there for you to make yours so
when you see our recipe later I'm going
to give you a principle not a recipe
right so then if you don't like that you
swap it out and if you don't like that
you swap it out but you will get a
delicious thing at the end of the
journey I think what's also smart about
it too is that I love growing gardens
like in so and so it's like oh what do I
grow because I like to eat a lot of
things I just don't know chemistry wise
how to put it together but even for that
it's like you look at those five
ingredients go okay so I'm going to
plant this I'll use that for the re I
love growing things as well me too but
like if if you limit it down and you're
like okay I'm going to do these recipes
so maybe I'll focus on growing these
that's easier too because it's so
overwhelming but I I have a garden and I
did a bunch of TV series in my garden I
didn't realize the biggest marijuana
plants had grown in the background and I
didn't plant them someone came in oh
shut up no I didn't I didn't these are
not mine it's this not how did these
marijuana plants get in here I'm sitting
there doing some sore and tacos and like
there's this big old Leaf hanging out
and I'm like damn but uh yeah funny I
feel like I'm introducing you poorly
because you are a knight in the UK so I
should say Sir Jamie Oliver I'm not a
knight no I got an MBE which is a member
of the British Empire I'll have you know
well what does that mean what does that
mean I got it actually when I was a very
young lad um it was for services to the
restaurant industry yeah and I set up a
restaurant my first restaurant um was
called 15 and every year we took 15 kids
from the projects or from prison or
homeless kids or kids that were just
sort of lost and then we gave him second
and third chances supported by
inspirational role models and it worked
worked and we did it for 17 years and it
worked and and what was beautiful is
it's that incredible story of
transformation can you change people if
you've got a trajectory of violence and
drugs and crime like can you go to
Michelin stars and interestingly two of
my we had like 480 students that go
through two have Michelin stars I
haven't even got one so they they got
better than me you know so um yeah it's
you you're a great teacher yes it's
that's cool the Mr Miyagi of chefs I
like it I mean I I love the idea of
whether it's the the public or people
teaching skills that switch on the
switch so you have your own fantasy and
your own Journey like you know just
switch on the buttons and and also if
you're most of the kids had struggled at
school like I did um and when you're one
of those kids that I mean in at my
country we call it special needs so it's
not the most glamorous name you get
pulled out of classes and all that but
with cooking every day you can learn
something valuable and even if you have
a bad day you can still learn stuff so
that idea of just filling people up and
letting them go on their journey is a
beautiful thing do you remember the
first meal you you must have been young
yeah I started cooking at eight I lived
in a pub restaurant um you were set up
to be successful okay no but I was the
FI kid at school like you know but I
like to earn money so um Dad said I'm
not going to give you money earn it so I
used to go in the kitchen prep peel you
know wash up yeah and and as school was
going like that at the weekends I was
like that so for me truly like cooking I
feel like saved saved I feel it music
did that for me I wasn't that kind of
kid either yeah everyone wants to be
good at something right so that first
meal it gives you confidence that can
carry over yeah and I remember I did a a
full I did a proper roast dinner with
all the trimmings potatoes gravy the
sauces how old were you 11 and and like
everything I hit it up a Hot Pocket in
the
microwave no I just remember my dad
saying well done son that was delicious
and I remember the hairs just go like
that was mine but yeah but I just come
out I just come from a parents evening
at school which was which was really bad
um so I'm like do yeah I think that I
think that's that's it yeah oh I I love
that I think it's important for kids to
find something that they find pride in
themselves and they feel confident in it
carries over yeah it can it can make
like if you learn to I call it like 10
recipes to save your life right truly
honestly if you I if I had a wish it
would be that every American kid leaves
at 16 knowing the 10 recipes to save
their life well they should teach this
in school they have to it would save the
money whether they're rich or poor they
would eat deliciously there'd be less
people going to hosit most of stuff
going through hospital is Diet related
disease it's all good so it's like just
and that adventure of cooking like like
convenience and all that has has helped
us but not helped us so yeah so that's
what I feel my journey is doing these
books and and and the TV shows that we
do and I've been doing it a long time I
know I look young guys but um I I'm like
25 years in the business I'm I'm
literally like I've been around a long
time it's cool though that you're still
inspired with these new ideas like you
20 cookbook I've never dried up thank
the Lord oh I think when I get bored
I'll just quit but I can I can just see
things and I fantasize and I I can
fantasize about we fantasize about
different things yeah I know but I
fantasize about that well you know the
two can come together oh beautiful
chocolate that might be my last book
there you go how to keep the fire
Al marriage five ways
with there's a lot of subliminal jokes
happening here but I think America's
with us I like it I you should be um so
do your kids do they get annoyed with
that you're famous they think it's still
cool because sometimes my kids think
it's cool but sometimes they're annoyed
because they're just like H I think
having a a parent that's well known is
very unhealthy and the statistics are
all there and and and it's like kids
just want to fit in and be normal and
then when you got a dad I mean I I got
told off my my daughter once I was
walking up it was parents evening I got
told off and I and I evaluated my body
and what I was doing and I realized the
only thing I had done was have a pulse
um like like it's just we're
embarrassing yeah to them you I think
I'm cool like like I've got my trainers
I got my top like I'm just like I'm just
like I'm just like I'm cool I'm at
school and then the kids and like
they're just so embarrassed and I'm not
cool yeah nobody which breaks my heart
um and and then like you're in the
parents evening and they kind of go um I
did that recipe the other day and um and
then they're like oh no so no it's it's
it's been a rough old ride at times yeah
yeah we just got to battle on yeah we're
just not cool I'm okay with it um do
strangers do they approach you with food
to try cuz I feel like people approach
me with songs yeah I've been given so
many weird and wonderful things do you
ever taste it because I'm kind of like
you shouldn't take a drink from a
stranger to Bar you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah you don't want to be doped I I have
been given my fair share of like um like
um cookies that have had certain things
put in them but no I I get given a lot
of stuff it's when they say do you want
to try it now oh and they're going live
on Instagram stories and it's like uh I
just had lunch I think oh I know I have
full on ask people have bought me stuff
too and I'm just like I and I don't know
why they well they must think I love
food um but they bring stuff and I'm I'm
afraid to try it but then that you feel
bad and I'm like if I get poisoned and
die from this this is how I'm going to
go out you got have some you got to have
some boundaries I know I know I'm bad
with that but in therapy um
well well here we go let's do another
commercial break uh Jamie is cooking for
us later in the show because I'm just
always trying to learn his new book five
ingredients Mediterranean is out now
it's really awesome you should get it
I'm going to try recipes from it no
doubt I'm going to post them and
[Music]
everything
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home